wie sah unser universum direkt nach dem
urknall aus und wie können wir uns die
urmaterie des kosmos vorstellen
antworten auf diese super spannenden
fragen hat jetzt ein us forschungsteam
gefunden
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler haben in ihren
experimenten in einem
teilchenbeschleuniger nämlich die
kleinsten quark gluon tröpfchen der welt
erzeugt also die urmaterie im miniformat
oder anders gesagt die ursuppe des
universums und diese besondere
flüssigkeit wird ganz besondere
überraschung klicks um science-fiction
hier gibt es täglich faszinierendes
seines videos aber nicht den kanal nur
dann verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
vor etwa 14 milliarden jahren war das
universum noch unfassbar klein und heißt
die ganze komprimiert der energie
explodierte und dehnte sich in
unendlicher geschwindigkeit aus kurz
nach diesem urknall entstanden dann nach
und nach die bausteine des lebens quarks
und gluonen als die ersten
elementarteilchen und später auch die
neutronen und protonen als bausteine für
die künftigen atomkerne das alte sich
weiter ab und erst bei rund 2700 grad
entstanden dann lithium helium und
wasserstoff atome alle bisherigen
experimente deuten also darauf hin dass
es direkt nach dem urknall weder atome
protonen neutronen gab schon dessen
existierte wohl etwa eine mikrosekunde
nach dem urknall eine art kosmischer
ursuppe aus einem plasma in dem sich
lohnen und quax frei bewegen
dieses sogenannte quark-gluon-plasma gp
kommt unter normalen bedingungen auf der
erde nicht vor es handelt sich hierbei
wirklich um eine besonders exotische
materie formt das standardmodell der
physik sagt ihre existenz voraus und
schon vor einiger zeit gelang es mit
teilchenbeschleunigern will sie
getroffen der materie experimentell
nachzuweisen und sogar künstlich
herzustellen wenn auch nur für einige
sekundenbruchteile
das entspricht in einigen aspekten
tatsächlich einen urknall im labor
doch dafür sind besonders extreme
bedingungen notwendig entweder muss eine
wirklich hohe materie dichte gegeben
sein oder aber eine extrem hohe
temperatur und zwar von etwa 10 auf 12
kelvin dass es etwa 70.000 mal heißer
als der mittelpunkt der sonne für eine
riesige waschung sorgte jetzt ein us
forschungsteam
für experimente nutzten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
den relativistische wie ein kleiner rsc
einen teilchenbeschleuniger in den usa
hier jagten die fachleute gold gerne mit
kleinen atomkerne aufeinander los durch
die kollision mit der terium kern
protonen und helium 3 kern entstanden
tatsächlich die kleinsten quark lohn
köpfchen der welt in gewisser weise eine
wissenschaftliche sensation auch für das
forschungsteam selbst der grund bisher
ging man davon aus dass solche
asymmetrischen kollision zum masse arm
sind um die notwendige energie
freizusetzen falsch gedacht und so
hatten sie quark-gluon-plasma erfolgt
das als die flüssig sste flüssigkeit des
universums gilt die viskosität also
quasi die zähflüssigkeit dieser ursuppe
und auch ihre reibung ist nahezu gleich
null zudem hat sie weitere wirklich
erstaunliche charakteristika sie ist
nämlich in der lage schneller zu
rotieren als alle anderen flüssigkeiten
wie wir sie kennen das
quark-gluon-plasma kommt auf
unglaubliche zehn milliarden mal in der
sekunde
damit erzeugt sie nach unserem jetzigen
wissensstand die wohl schnellsten wirbel
im ganzen universum das aktuelle
experiment aus den usa enthüllt ein
weiteres überraschendes merkmal der
materie die kleinen tröpfchen verfügen
alle über verblüffende geometrische
formen die um 3 kern erinnern an ein
dreieck das quark-gluon-plasma aus den
kollision der protonen war kugelförmig
und das bedeute und verfügte über eine
elliptische vor genau dies hatten
vorherige theoretische modelle auf
vorhergesagt ganz einfach deswegen weil
die geometrischen merkmale der ursprungs
atomkerne erhalten bleiben erklärt die
pressesprecherin julia belkowski wir
sehen starke korrelation zwischen der
ursprünglichen geometrie und den
späteren fliesst mustern und das
aktuelle experiment verrät uns auch noch
mehr über unser universum direkt nach
dem urknall dazu eine der beteiligten
wissenschaftlerinnen jamie nagel
unsere ergebnisse haben damit uns näher
an eine antwort auf die frage gebracht
welches die kleinstmögliche größe ist in
der diese urmaterie existieren kann das
experiment des forschungsteams trägt
damit einen großen teil zum
fundamentalen verständnis der entstehung
des universums und dem aufbau der
materie bei auch wenn solche
experimentellen erfolge in der
teilchenphysik zunächst erst mal nicht
direkt industriellen anwendung zu gute
kommt denn das kann man sich vorstellen
dafür sind die herstellungsbedingungen
noch etwas zu extrem und das
quark-gluon-plasma zu kurz nämlich aber
so oder so geht es in der wissenschaft
schritt für schritt und auf die eine
bahnbrechende entdeckung folgt die
nächste oder auch die nächste erfindung
auf jeden fall erleben wir eine rasante
technische und wissenschaftliche
entwicklung und damit wir hier bei klick
so hinterher kommen brauchen wir eure
mithilfe macht uns mit dem hashtag tv
für den vorschlag bei whatsapp
themenvorschläge dafür hier klicken
meldet euch an ist vollkommen kostenlos
was habt ihr für interessante news
entdeckt welche themen findet er
spannend wir sind gespannt und setzen ja
ihr immer wieder eure vorschläge um und
können euren weiteren input kaum
erwarten also vielen dank an die box
hepp community von hier aus schon mal
bis dann bleibt dran